the holiday classic how the Grinch Stole
Christmas by dr. Seuss has been given an
animated makeover by the team behind the
despicable Me movies yippee-ki-yay movie
lovers it's Jan here and today I'm
explaining the biggest differences
between illuminations new Grinch movie
the sixties animated TV special and the
live-action film with Jim Carrey keep
watching to the end for a bonus Grinch
Easter egg and subscribe and leave a
comment about the movie for a chance to
win some awesome Grinch merchandise the
first big difference that you'll notice
between this particular Grinch in
previous versions is that the filmmakers
have deliberately made him a little more
likeable and relatable that's because
they felt a very nasty Grinch would be
too off-putting in a feature-length
festive film so they sanded down his
spiky edges somewhat another big change
in this version is that the filmmakers
delve into why the Grinch became the way
he is in the original book a made-for-tv
animation the Grinch didn't have any
real backstory
we just knew he'd hated Christmas for 53
years likely because his heart was two
sizes too small the live-action film
however did add some background
information with baby Grinch arriving by
accident in Whoville getting adopted by
elderly women falling for a girl at
school and being bullied by his
classmates which made the young Grinch
leave town for Mount crumpit like that
movie the new animation returns to the
Grinch's youth for answers though this
time his emotional pain stems from a
childhood spent in an orphanage where he
was basically abandoned during Christmas
by bringing up the Grinch his backstory
the filmmakers wanted to soften off
feelings towards him and open up a path
for him to heal over the course of the
story indeed according to Benedict
Cumberbatch once you understand why
Christmas is painful for him you kind of
root for him a little but what about the
new Grinch his appearance
well although in his 1957 book he
started out black and white with pinky
colored eyes thanks to the 1966
animation Green is very much the color
associated with a holiday hating
character and as you'd expect
just like the live-action movie in 2000
illuminations animated feature sticks
with green though it does make some
changes giving his teeth a cosmetic
makeover and adding pink ellipse and
green on white eyes in a chair
from the pinky red on yellow eyes of the
sixties animation and the green on
yellow eyes of the live-action this
Grinch also looks brighter softer better
groomed and less creepy than previous
versions which I imagine was done to
make him look more appealing the amazing
progress in animation tools and
techniques since the early cartoon means
there's a real sense of texture to the
Grinch his hair in this new film the
wavy effect in his fur feels like a nod
to the characters drawings in the book
the far as the other characters go the
filmmakers have gone for a less zany
look that's more human and largely cuter
than in previous adaptations as they
wanted the movie to appeal to a broad
audience including people who'd never
seen the original dr. Seuss and Chuck
Jones artwork the Greta's dog Max has
been part of his story since the
original book but in this new version
the relationship between Max and the
Grinch is much more developed max isn't
just a pet or substitute reindeer he's
everything to the Grinch including his
best friend his pretty much constant
companion and his devoted right-hand dog
in fact Max's incredible loyalty to his
green friends is designed to help earth
see the goodness in the Grinch someone
else he's been part of the grouchy green
character story from the very beginning
is cindy-lou who in the book and TV
special she's just 2 years old and her
only real interaction with the Grinch is
when she chances upon him while he's
disguised as Santa and asks why he's
taking her family's Christmas tree the
new movie like the Jim Carrey film ages
cindy-lou up several years and greatly
expands her storyline in the live-action
Cindy Lou has more interaction with the
Grinch than in this film though
illuminations movie still gives her an
active role which involves her trying to
trap Santa she wants him to help out her
tired overworked mother there's also a
whole host of new characters introduced
in this film not content with just
having one adorable creature on screen
the new movie adds a reindeer called
Fred who I can absolutely see being a
favorite with kids and selling a ton of
toy as much like max Fred appears when
the Grinch starts to put together his
plot to steal Christmas and he's not
only a nice comic foil to the Grinch is
grumpiness Bert as with max he also lets
us see a different side to the green
Christmas thief another new animal
addition to the story is a wild goat and
although he's not on screen very long he
definitely leaves an impression thanks
to his rather distinctive voice which
adds to the film's comedy another new
face in Whoville is the Grinch's nearest
neighbor mr. brickle Bamm
he's the happiest who alive and
considers himself to be the Grinch his
best friend though the Grinch of course
has an entirely different view of the
situation Brickel bomb who's voiced by
Saturday Night Live star Kenan Thompson
is full of Christmas spirit and just
adores covering his house in lights and
breaking out his huge selection of Santa
and snowman inflatables to celebrate the
holidays basically he's another obstacle
in the way of the Grinch his isolation
and the Grinch doesn't like it one bit
also not in the original book or TV
special is the mayor of who-ville now if
you know the live-action version you'll
remember there was a mare in that film
and he was an entirely nasty piece of
work in fact he was the reason why the
Grinch cut himself off from society
however in illuminations film the myrrh
isn't a baddie she's a completely
different character and it's a real
treat to hear her played by Angela
Lansbury while Cyndi whose parents
aren't mentioned in the book or TV
animation they do make an appearance in
the live-action movie where her father
is the town's postmaster and her mother
competes to have the best lights in
Whoville in a complete change in the new
animation
Cindy Liu's mom Donna is a frazzled
hard-working single parent with three
children and she's voiced by Parks and
Rec star rashida Jones similar to the
live-action father though this new
animated mother realizes that Christmas
is about much more than things Cindy Lou
needs some help to carry out her plan to
trap Santa so she turns to her friends
who were all new additions to the
popular story
there's her best friend group pert as
well as the brains of the outfit Izzie
the laid-back axle and the wisecracking
Ozzy in the book there's only a handful
of houses shown in Whoville and although
the number of colorful Hugh homes more
or less triples in the TV special it's
still a tiny town in the live-action
movie Whoville got much bigger and more
detailed with a post office stores and a
school and it was also an excess of
festive lights ornaments and presents as
the hoos were more materialistic
illuminations new film takes things in a
different direction may
who-ville's houses stores businesses and
vehicles reflect the warm and welcoming
nature of the who's the new Whoville is
a vibrant town full of vivid colors in
fact it appears so sweet and inviting
that it looks like it could be made of
gingerbread
by the way when creating Whoville the
film makers made sure they avoided
straight lines were possible to keep a
similar vibe to dr. Seuss's work
story-wise there are some interesting
differences between all the versions of
the Grinch's tale the only time the
Grinch visits Whoville in both the book
and the sixties animation is to carry
out his plan to steal Christmas in the
live-action film however the Grinch
visited Whoville several times before
trying to steal their big day first he
went to cause trouble after some Hughes
disturbed him on Mount crumpit and later
he returned his holiday cheermeister for
the whose seasonal celebration the new
animated movie also shows the Grinch
descending from his mountain home before
his big robbery but this time it's
because he's run out of groceries after
stress eating his way through all the
food in his house ahead of Christmas he
later ends up in Whoville again after
his plan to launch a huge snowball at
the town goes wrong while all the
versions of the story show how much the
Grinch hates all the noise of Christmas
the new animated movie ups the stakes as
the Grinch is faced with the prospect of
the noisiest holiday season ever as this
year who-ville's mayor wants the
festivities to be three times bigger
than usual of course the Grinch really
can't stand the idea of that which leads
him to steal Christmas to stop the noisy
madness of it all I mentioned earlier
that Whoville is much bigger in this
film and that means that the Grinch is
planned to rob the whose turns out to be
much more challenging than previous
adaptations in fact this time it's a
whole big production more akin to a huge
heist so expect to see the Grinch get
really creative using a massive range of
crazy Rube Goldberg style contraptions
that reminded me a lot of the kind of
stuff you see in Altman's Wallace and
Gromit films Owen the Grinch is cave is
also full of ridiculous high-tech
gadgets and gives most to if you're a
fan of the songs from the original
animation you'll be pleased to hear the
new movie features both welcomed
Christmas which gets a pretty familiar
interpretation and you're a mean one mr.
Grinch which is given a totally
different spin
there's also a new song I'm the Grinch
which plays over the closing credits
singer/songwriter Pharrell Williams he
provides a lovely and suitably warm
narration for the new film certainly had
big shoes to fill as generations have
grown up hearing Boris Karloff lend his
inimitable voice to the TV special as
for the new script it mixes dr. Seuss's
original language with new dialogue and
narration so in addition to many classic
lines you'll also hear new material that
aims to reflect the style and spirit of
the original Pharrell's vocal
performance in the grinch is also an
illumination Easter egg as the
singer/songwriter has composed themes
and songs including the oscar-nominated
happy for the despicable Me movies and
I'll be talking about lots more
illumination Easter eggs and my things
you missed in the Grinch video which you
can tap here to watch or click the link
at the end or in the video description
below now which is your favorite version
of The Grinch and what do you like best
about the new movie let me know in the
comments below and remember to subscribe
for a chance to win one of these cool
Grinch merch packs I've got new videos
on the Grinch coming up so tapleft to
watch the next one or tap write for
another video you're sure to like if you
enjoyed this I really appreciate a
thumbs up and a share thanks for
watching and see you next time you PK
will be lovers
you